I connected with Kelly Rowland to talk
about her beautiful new project regular
heroes but let's be honest we had to
address what is going on in Minneapolis
and around this country right now and
Kelly's emotions echoed what so many
people are feeling today you see the
stuff happening in our country right now
how are you digesting all this I can't
I'm angry um hurt at times feeling
hopeless but then sometimes like I look
at my son or like hell no I gotta keep
going
and what do I need to do feeling for the
families that have to go through all
this communities all their emotions just
makes me angry
Kelly was emotional talking about George
Floyd and other reason events in the
country hours after we spoke the
situation escalated into riots fires set
in protests and a CNN news crew was
arrested on live TV yesterday I was just
mad like read mag and then last night it
was like tough to sleep I'm happy that
it's actually bothering us - the way it
is now because that's what action
happens but we need a way to move
together because if we moving we're just
acting out of all this anger and madness
and emotion it's we we have to be
collected and unified Kelly is also busy
focusing on the good and all those who
give back to their communities she's
hosting an episode of the new 8 part
docu-series called regular heroes new
episodes air every Friday on Amazon we
are actually really thanking people and
giving back this is another form of
giving back and and you just want to
celebrate those who are just putting
their lives their family's lives on the
line and it's beautiful next topic
a few other celebrities also show up in
the series and that sound recognise me
when i zoom by okay yeah yeah okay not
that many people look like Kevin Hart
[Music]
who's been the most memorable everyday
hero in your life during this time my
husband says the sweetest things and
wants to be supportive I love him
[Music]